the Atlantic system is is the worst this
is why I say the worst this is why we
should focus on the west that trade uh
between the American colonies uh Latin
America Europe and Africa that was
absolutely indispensable everything we
think about Industrial Revolution the
Scientific Revolution the political
revolution would not have been possible
without the Atlantic system now that's
important because
what was the basis of the Atlantic
system it wasn't just Commerce and
Industry it was a particular kind of
Commerce and Industry at the time when
Columbus sailed the ocean blue Europe
was behind one of the few places in the
world that was emerging from a Dark Age
and in order to to create this Atlantic
system which produced the wealth and the
basis of the economy that we have today
uh the the West the European nations had
to literally hack burn and roast their
way into progress Columbus set off the
largest genocide in human history so in
the Americas we rarely talk about this
but they're up to and I was I was
actually surprised at the numbers when I
was writing the book the midpoint
estimate of the amounts of deaths in the
Americas after European contact is 68
million I believe and if you just look
at his what was then Hispaniola the
midpoint estimate and so it could be
higher could be lower but the midpoint
estimate of inhabitants of the island
when Columbus landed was 8 million by
the time Columbus left in 1512 the mid
their midpoint estimate again is a
hundred thousand and by um 1542 there
were only 200 natives left in fact up to
98 99 of some of the native population
are literally are raised from the Earth
but that was necessary that was the
clearing the way for the this Atlantic
system to come in to be right that we
can kind of imagine that could it have
happened another way it happened this
way and this way meant that the Americas
became the Garden of Eden for Europe it
became the place where Europeans have
all Hues um classes could go to make
their wealth Etc and absolutely and that
genocide is absolutely essential to
allowing that to happen the other really
key building point of the Atlantic
system of course is the slave trade
slavery again utterly indispensable once
the natives had been exhausted for their
labor Europeans needed to turn somewhere
else and where did they turn they turned
to Africa and for two to three hundred
years depending uh took millions of
young working age Africans stolen from
the continent at the the lowest estimate
is that 12 million people were forcibly
transported from Africa to the Americas
and the lowest estimate again is that
double that number died either on the
continent or in transit so the minimum
talking about is 36 million people taken
out of Africa to fulfill this trade and
again remember what was the key
Commodities that built the worst sugar
and cotton tobacco they're all these
things which were absolutely essential
right so here you can see in the
Americas the building blocks of
imperialism and also that wealth
remember at the time before Columbus the
West was behind it was the Well from the
Atlantic system that enabled uh the West
to take over the rest of the world to
take over the East Etc and from here you
can see a very clear logic of white
supremacy that black and brown life is
disposable in the pursuit of Western
progress it began in 1492 it becomes
cemented in the set in the centuries
that follow and then you and and it
becomes even more cemented in this
scholarship in the work in the
enlightenment in Western European
thought it is not coincidental that it
took a couple of hundred years after
Columbus I mean the the age of so-called
reason is after the West has laid waste
to the large parts of the world after
we've been that the West has enslaved
believed millions of people after the
West has taken over the world and then
you have these figures like Emmanuel can
like lock like Rousseau theorizing from
a place of white supremacy saying look
this is how the world is the way white
people must be superior because look
we're sweet period and this becomes the
basis of our thought even today
unfortunately this hierarchy where you
have white under top black on the bottom
and everywhere else in between moving to
the present day if you look at global
inequality it shouldn't surprise us to
find that we've actually created the
world in the image of white supremacy
the poorest part of the world is
so-called sub-Saharan Africa the richest
parts of the world
um are the west where white people live
right there's a hierarchy in between of
white supremacy we have literally
created the world an image of white
supremacists and what happened and what
changed is the old system and this is
why I call it the new age the old system
of imperialism European dominated
Empires large-scale violence that
couldn't hold forever for one there is
resistance there is revolts there were
rebellions it was not possible to keep
subjugating people in that manner uh the
second part the Empire's Collide the
Empire's collapse what are the second of
the first world war in particular the
second world war but Empires collect
um Empires coming to a head right and
the third thing that we see very clearly
with the Knights is is the boomerang
effect uh what um Amos is there calls
the boomerang effect where racism
fascism the logic of white supremacy
comes into Europe and becomes enacted on
white bodies and everybody turns around
and goes wow this was a really bad idea
so after the second world war this that
old system can't maintain and what
happens is there is a shift there is a
shift where it's no longer European
Empires that dominate it is America the
dominates it's not a coincident the
United States the commons a new seat
that was kind of always logical given
that you United States is just a more
extreme version of Europe a place where
Europeans could act in Ultimate
barbarism to
um maximize their resources we have a
shift away from not completely but
mostly away from the kind of violence
that was associated with slavery in the
Imperial Imperial era at this point it's
not necessary because you've already
underdeveloped the world you've already
created the conditions where the West is
on top and so now we have Financial no
great time to do this
to do it now okay
advanced technology uh has infiltrated
this debate you have a minute to
memorize okay sorry okay one minute I'm
gonna go
um don't know where was I so this was
the end anyway so yeah you have economic
um world Bank IMF you uh the UN even in
global imbalances in trade in trade Etc
and so a one step I will end with here
which I think makes the point nine
million people die every year through
hunger a child dies every 10 seconds
because they don't have access to food
all of those children almost all of them
exclusively are black and brown the
logic of Empire is still very much with
us it is delivered in a different way
but the mechanism is still there and it
goes back to the very founding of what
the West is the West is white supremacy
and it cannot be anything else
thank you very much for for coming there
I think there's absolutely on point on
on the on the clock
um well that makes really a very strong
case there for Kinder's argument uh as
laid out in the New Age of Empire but
delving back into the roots and where he
sees that taking the world that we live
in today and the arguments all around us
Jeremy black also historian uh author of
many books including a brief history of
slavery and the British Empire history
in a debate uh into Alia
um Jeremy you have your 10 minutes
beginning now on why the West is not
fundamentally racist
well could I take up some of kalinda's
points and I want to look at some of
them empirically just items of fact and
some of them conceptually and then what
I'm always interested when historians
disagree
um I want to try and give some
historiographical basis so as you know
won't surprise people that I I'm not uh
of the same mind
um for example I don't see the
demographics as being the the same as
kalindi does uh I would argue that most
of the deaths in the Caribbean that
occurred were a result of influenza and
smallpox and not as he calls it genocide
that the very last thing that the
Spaniards wanted to do was to have to
buy a labor force in Africa and
transport it across the Atlantic and if
you look at colonies like Peru or Mexico
there are relatively few African slaves
because the majority of the population
doesn't die in some kind of genocide and
remains as you know if clindy visits
Latin America today he will find that in
much of Latin America you can see very
readily in DNA work will also
substantiate it there are The
Descendants of those people who were
there prior to the Spaniards so I don't
recognize the demography and whilst I
agree with him that roughly 11 to 12
million people were transported across
the Atlantic I think his figure that
twice that number died in transit is
just fanciful it's not what the
specialist literature on the subject
argues and again I I would be
disinclined to agree with him about the
salience of sugar and cotton to me the
key Commodities are coal and iron and I
read his book with some interest I
thought it you know it's arguing a case
very clearly and he's cogent and fluent
but I think he's inclined to leave out
what doesn't fit in I mean quite clearly
there has been a lot of whatever we
might refer to as racism in the history
of the West that is not the same thing
as saying that the West is fundamentally
about races and I think there is a
slippage there in the analysis which is
problematic let's just put it like that
and again for example if you come to the
enlightenment now as kalindi will know
there is an enormous literature on the
enlightenment it's been discussed in
very many different ways and as he
eloquently argues there is a new left
critique of it rather old left actually
by now but which presents it in the
terms he does actually ironically if you
think about this in 18th century terms
the whole point about the enlightenment
was that it was a movement of cultural
relativism the belief was among
Enlightenment figures that
um far from Western Society necessarily
being the Supreme example or Acme of
quality there was this fascination with
the Orient in particular and there was
also an interest strong interest in as
it were New Frontiers particularly in
the South Seas so again I would argue
and you know I don't think this would be
much of a surprise to Specialists on the
enlightenment
um that in fact the enlightenment is
about cultural relativism far more than
kalindi portrays it as a matter of white
supremacist and you know if you look for
example at Gibbons uh discussion of of
um history and as you may know Gibbons
actually his book is books go up to the
mid 16th century or if you look at
William Robertson or if you look at Adam
Smith I think all of their accounts of
History rather exemplify this as indeed
does Voltaire
um if you're looking at distinctive
features of the West as an imperial
system I wouldn't say it's specifically
or specifically or principally racist I
mean I think that you would get whatever
you might mean by racism or tribalism or
whatever you mean by it I think it's
fairly continual and constant in in
world history I think the major
difference I would focus on the for the
west and shall we say the 16th 17th or
18th centuries as opposed to the other
major area of the world which had
um as it were the economic and
demographic weight
um to move to move towards great
Imperial strength which is the various
societies of east and south Asia the
principal difference is the West is very
multi-polar doesn't in fact end up with
one land power that is dominant
um where so that you know you mention
you argue that gold and silver comes in
from the new world and sort of powers
everything actually gold and silver
helped to power Spanish power uh Spanish
strength and obviously Spain failed uh
to become the great power of the late
16th early 17th century It Was Defeated
now the contrast is more readily with
China which by 1800 has got about 300
million people Europe about then is 60
million and China of course is one state
and that is a very different nature and
I would argue that if you're looking at
Western imperialism uh the the constant
is this multipolarity and it also means
that Western Powers have spent more of
their time fighting each other than
they've fought non-westerners and again
that doesn't really emerge adequately in
Calendar's book so that if you wish to
argue as you know well some people do
that Britain is a racist Society I
personally think that's misleading but
if you wish to argue that you have to
really explain why the British devoted
most of the last half Millennium to
fighting the Spaniards the French the
Germans and not bro rata elsewhere
um so as I said I think there is a level
of complexity and I'm rather you know
I'd like to think of four-dimensional
historian with time as the fourth
dimension and I would argue that you
need to have far more complexity than
was offered by the very eloquence of our
opening speaker but the last point on
the present day we will obviously have
very differing accounts of what is going
on at the present moment but I noticed
and I the the comments about what is
really horrible levels of poverty in
parts of the third world it is also
worth bearing in mind that some former
colonized areas or areas of Imperial
power so let's say for Britain you know
parts of South and East Asia have done
extremely well some former colonies the
Japanese colony of South Korea for
example extremely successful I don't
think Imperial rule itself explains why
States cannot take off and my last point
and this is looking at the world I'm
sure many of us are shocked at what's
going on in myanimar Burma at the
present moment I I personally am also
been very shocked at the counts coming
out of Ethiopia of the fighting there I
think we have to accept that just as
there have been horrible things done by
Western Powers so there have been
horrible things done by non-western
Powers virtue is not a monopoly of
anyone's State and I also feel that as
it were banging on I sat and to think
Lindy got it wrong but you know he'll
have his point of view banging on about
the 16th century does not help us very
much in discussing the iniquities the
inequalities and the cruelty of the
Modern Age it doesn't help us even more
if our accounts of the past are actively
misleading and if this actively
misleading quality is then propagated in
the modern world thank you very much